[Applause]
thousands of protesters calling
themselves whistleblowers greeted
President Donald Trump in Minneapolis
demanding his impeachment the largest
crowd of demonstrators in recent months
turned a chant Trump fans once reserved
for Hillary Clinton back on the
president it was Trump's first rally
since an inquiry into impeachment
proceedings began on September 24th
support the values surrounded by
thousands of supporters of his own in
one of the longest speeches of his
presidency Trump fired back in his
latest assault on a favorite target
former vice president and Democratic
presidential rival Joe Biden he was only
a good vice president because he
understood how to kiss Barack Obama's
ass speaking in her own congressional
district Trump portrayed Minneapolis his
own Ilhan omar's the face of the
Democratic Party is in America hating
socialists how do you have such a person
representing you in Minnesota I'm very
angry at you people right now outside
protesters and Trump fans were a picture
of a nation divided it came hours after
FBI agents at Washington's Dulles
Airport arrested two Soviet born men who
were linked to the president's attorney
Rudolph Giuliani over alleged campaign
finance violations the three are shown
together here on a social media post
leading the cheering crowd inside the
arena was the man who would be President
if Trump were impeached vice president
Mike Pence in a state the president
narrowly lost in 2016 and hopes to win
in 2020
to erase your vote like it never existed
they want to erase your voice and they
want to erase your future but they will
fail because in America the people rule
again outside in the liberal bastion of
Minneapolis the calls for his removal
from office grew louder Jon Hendren al
jazeera minneapolis